all right welcome to part 2 of LED live
this is love is what and that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
love we're talking about sexuality and
in portent we're gonna be talking a
little bit about pornography we're gonna
talk about some statistics on where
society is changing morally on various
relationship views make sure you check
out part 1 if you haven't seen the part
2 because it's kind of foundational and
you want to build with us on what we
talked about in part 1 and buckle your
seatbelts because we're about to go for
a fast paced ride this is love is what
led live check it out find out on this
episode of LED live so movies TV
magazines what about social media though
with social media you find that there is
increased pressure PDA so let's PDF
public display of affection when you see
what everyone else is doing the pressure
is up to keep up that image because
you're competing with the Joneses
everybody on the Internet is now the
Joneses now once again just like the
cover of Cosmopolitan right there was
900 photos taken to get that one photo
for that girl right if you look at how
much most people post to get that photo
mm-hmm you know maybe they've taken tons
of photos or whatever to get to that one
so a lot of times it's it's it's a very
contrived view of what's going on as
well I guess we should probably do
another shameless plug here we have a
documentary on social media that talks
about some of this in more detail it's
called the hashtag selfie and we'll also
put that link you know thinking about
scenes of that movie when you brought
this up tell us something about PDA in
general or how its presented nowadays
cuz I think there's a place for it for
sure
remember when gender Babylon check that
out it's one of our LED live episodes
you talking about you know how does how
you interact with your wife or even how
you touch your kids it's it's important
to do that so they understand what is
appropriate touch versus been
appropriate today so we're talking about
with the
Advent of social media and people
putting up all manner of pictures
there's a heightened awareness of what
everybody else is doing and therefore
you now feel compelled that you must
also show you know your public display
of affection and you know how far do you
go because some people aren't really
putting the brakes on it also makes it
easy to overestimate levels of intimacy
you don't know the whole story you only
know what you see on the screen yeah
that picture is a snapshot in time and
we're all good at like you know putting
on the smile just for the picture right
you know so you also compare yourself
with others you want to see what
everybody else is doing
aside from in person flirting social
media is the most common way to teens
express interest in someone they have a
crush on my wife right in most cases
this is actually how they only
communicate I mean some feels
interesting through social media I mean
they're like literally instagramming
each other pictures of themselves and
that's how the relationship goes you
know I seen a recent TED talk video
where a lady was basically saying you
know the internet Facebook for example
is like the new little black book of the
internet and that some people are like I
should keep up this relationship with
this person I know over here because
what if things don't work out in this
relationship over here even if you're in
a married long-term relationship they're
like still keeping somebody an open door
yeah open door because hey what if
things don't work out what am i what am
I going and for a female really
communication is the real relationship
right I mean that's the intimacy is that
communication the sex is really a a side
note to that relationship and so you
know you got to be careful with that
because even as a female you're keeping
these relationships alive with all these
other people and that's getting fed and
that's what they're really after so I
mean there's there's there's caution
here to to you know guard your marriage
or guard that relationship well my wife
is always telling me she says you don't
talk enough talk to me more come home
you know how was your day it's mine she
so she should gradually adjusts the
question she's gotten wise you tell me
about your day right yeah I'm just not
not a big talker you know I do these
things and I go and present and it's
sometimes people get the idea I'm just
you know talk talk talk I'm more of a
quiet reserved person but you're right
females desire that communication they
want you to talk to that they want you
to communicate and that's a foundational
principle in your marriage if you're not
communicating yeah but how do you guys
feel you know when you finally get it
off your chest you know and you finally
have a conversation
oh my Chatty Cathy said too much
[Laughter]
technology can make teens feel more
connected and closer to their partner I
can also cause feelings of jealousy and
uncertainty and they're almost social
media the problem with all this
technology is when you're communicating
there can oftentimes be a lot of
ambiguity one of the ways that we now
used or express ourselves because it it
works a little bit better is emojis if
you think about it right because you
can't see emotion on the other end of a
device you don't you don't always just
see that to people they can read the
same thing to take it completely
differently depending on their
personality that's why I use all caps
yeah this guy's yelling I was just
saying it loudly yeah let me go through
a number of statistics here from
different sources like Pew Research
which is what this one comes from it
says the leading reasons why teenagers
in the u.s. feel the social media has a
mostly negative effect on people their
own age and this is as of 2018 in April
so a little over a year ago number one
reason bullying and rumor spreading my
niece was bullied through social media
she was new in high school and they
somehow either reposted some pictures or
whatever and and it really really
bothered her pretty bad she almost
wanted to change schools
so III know this their first-hand
experience through my family I think
what's really interesting on here is you
would think that people would just be
tired of the drama it's only a 3%
there's all these other issues that
they're self identifying and saying no
it's it's fully removing its harmful
very relationship it's unrealistic views
of other's lives
well let's take a look at what Barna
Group said is they called they had an
article on their site called porn 2.0
the sexting crisis very provocative
title right port 2.0 offers much of the
same promise as traditional pornography
a disembodied visual experience without
the attachments or intimacy of sex and
yet there is a variety here as well
because the truth is sexting often
happens well before a relationship
begins in those early get-to-know-you
stages and it's not all unlikely that a
person is sexting with multiple
potential partners at any one time if
he's asking you for pictures he's
probably asking someone else for
pictures - good point
all right so this is changed the
paradigm you know cuz when we were
growing up you know to get a picture you
had to take a picture take it to get it
developed all this stuff now you
literally could in in a moment of
whatever excitement take a picture
yourself and hit Send and like oh I
can't believe what I just did now it's
out there to be passed around like wow
and if it's ever used against you which
I'm sure happens a lot
you know it can destroy people's lives
and I mean think of the stress of being
a team already and then all of a sudden
now you have this public life where
everybody has a phone it can easily be
texted to everyone real fast
it's a terrible terrible thing there are
apps on the App Store that are private
photo vaults right the icon looks like
something else a calculator app yeah it
looks like the calculator app or
whatever and you have to use a password
to get into it right or your thumb you
know for touch ID or whatever because
people are trying to hide things like
that they don't want anybody else to see
you know mom get your phone and opens it
up what pictures have you been taking
you know it's a way that you can hide
you know what's going on in your life
I'm crazy Katie's baby say like man I'm
so happy I'm an 80s baby I was able to
do all my stupidity before social media
yeah never broadcast everywhere well the
same report went on and it said it's
porn 2.0 as user-created often shared
with a known person a friend or
significant other or a potential
romantic interest you know what I'm
talking about
sexting snapchat a nude pictures posting
provocative Instagram photos hmm this is
amazing what's going on these days we
know that in 2018 teen smartphone use is
at 91% as compared to 2011 it was only
36% we've talked about it being a source
of influence a source of information
right and now it's nearly omnipresent I
mean just whatever you want whenever you
want
so 2017 New York Times did a study and
it shows that teens and adults check
their smartphones at least 150 times per
day
oh and text at least a hundred and ten
times per day this does not even include
Instagram snapchat and other texting
just the text it's just so it's so
prevalent in society it's so accessible
so easy really to do good or evil
right because technology is is a tool
you can use it to do good you can use it
to do evil it's made it's so easy to do
some of those things have you hurt you
in meeting the ghost vibes goes fiber
people I don't even have their phone in
their pocket yeah yeah yeah I like they
feel it and yeah no there's nothing
there they're feeling the vibration
you're used to like that text feeling so
they're getting it even when it's not
happy
yeah totally happens me yeah yeah
in 2011 1% of kids eight years and under
and tablets in 2017
42% do wow there's a lot of tablets just
being handed out to get yeah I would
like to compare bedrooms yeah
kids and even the early 90s versus in it
and you were really careful with a
device that's connected to the Internet
you know I mean even through kids kids
apps I have heard that some of them have
chat rooms and adults can get on those
kids apps and start communicating with
the kids it's really alarming so as a
parent you really need to be cautious
with giving your kid and the open-ended
device like that suggestion if they got
to play with it play with it in an open
room back in the bedroom with closed
doors not a good idea to turn on the
Internet off of it let them play their
little games or what yeah yeah download
the videos that you want all right
that's right disconnected from the
internet exactly and and so just a great
segue for that is our next statistic
where it says 50% of teens aged 13 to 19
or 18 frequently communicate online with
someone they've never met in person
Wow 50% they do percent that's carry a
lot of strangers out there there's a lot
of strangers and get strange ideas and
people doing weird thing yeah you really
want to like have a sleepless night
start watching those Dateline things of
those child molesters that get online
and you'll never sleep again another
kitchen and then a selfie documentary
the guy pretended to be a yeah I don't
remember he got he got a 13 year old
girl to meet him though yeah 12 13 and
14 year old girl baby I mean it happens
at all ages it's so easy to deceive
people on the internet because I'm
really on the other side they really
have no idea who is there or anything
about you you can put a persona out and
it's just it's so easy hmm so really
disturbing along with that is that one
in five children will be approached by a
sexual predator online one for one in
five twenty percent and that's just
online not counting real-world sexual
predators right and and the danger
really becomes is when this crosses into
that reality not that this isn't a
danger but even a more a danger you know
and then you could have a child
kidnapped or assaulted or what-have-you
it gets it gets really scary when it
comes to online present technology and
kids and all that often times you know
when we talk to parents and do seminars
and stuff they I almost have like this
what do we do almost like the parents
are helpless like remember you're the
parent exactly right you it's still your
home it's still your devices you know
you have to make the rules you know what
it is that you want your kid to do and
not to do and I realize from talking to
it like a lot of moms for example they
say we don't know the technology that
well and we don't know what to do and so
that's one thing I have a passion to do
that hopefully we can work toward in the
future is showing them some of those
tools on what can I do as a parent
what are those settings I need to say
you know what does it mean when I put a
firewall on my router or whitelist web
sites versus blacklist websites or terms
or whatever you know parents need to be
educated about those kinds of things
otherwise you're just
it's open season on on your kid more
than 58% of children's surveyed ages 14
to 17 report having seen a pornographic
site on the internet or on their all it
takes as a kid that it's been exposed
and I know how to spell and they get
their parents phone and game over there
they just they want to share you know
sin is very contagious if you will you
know it wants to spray it everywhere
like a disease you made a comment about
flip phones and you guys grew up with
flip flop flip phones even when I grew
up you see what's still exposed to this
stuff without the technology we have
today yeah you know for for parents I
think they need to talk about it with
their kids before their kids are exposed
to it
I think responses or knowledge is
everything so if the kid understands
that I think when they're confronted
with it it won't be they're responsible
and be curiosity I think you'll be like
whoa I shouldn't watch this and turn to
something else hopefully yeah they
actually say I watched a really amazing
presentation on this exact topic when do
you talk about this with your kids how
do you started begin to open this out
and the lady was basically saying you
want to beat your kid to the punch you
want to give them because they're gonna
be naturally curious my kids have
already come my daughter actually has
already come to my wife and and started
questioning her about sexuality she's
nine years old and it really gave my
wife an opportunity to take a step back
talk to her about the amazing gift that
God created us to have together and and
showed it in its proper light before
some other kid educated her and now she
has a proper context that came from her
mother and and she understands now the
the context of it so now when she's
introduced to it from a little kid at
school or somebody comes to say
something she has on and
I know that's not right this is right
and that's part of the problem as
parents that don't say anything to their
kids and then all of a sudden some of
the kids gonna tell your kid I mean that
you pretty much can't control or they
just hide it like it's taboo which makes
the kid even more curious well I'm gonna
find out one way or another and then
they're only gonna say that yeah we've
got to start having these conversations
with our kids and the reality of the
situation is by by age 10 11 12 13
oftentimes it's too late and it's the
kind of education as well I mean you
don't want to scare the kid you also
don't want to leave it open-ended
because predators look out for scared
children vulnerable children so having a
child having understanding and also
being confident and okay if this is a
situation I'm faced with this is how I
should react this how I can get out of
it it's really important and this is
another thing that happens when you put
it in the proper context as well that
the child feels safe to come and talk
with you about that conversation if they
were exposed to a dirty magazine or a
video or something
they immediately I mean every kid knows
this is wrong like I should not be
seeing this and minutes are really and
it's a it's a real like fearful thing I
don't want to talk with my parent about
it because I've seen something that I
know I shouldn't have seen and so that
topic then becomes in the shadows and
that's where the devil can really get
ahold of their mind and and and grow
that sin is when this stuff is not
people to be brought out into the light
so you want to keep those clear
communications as a parent keep that
communication and be able to feel like a
safe place for your child to come and
have those conversations with your
parent or even in shows like who's
training your kids it's not cool and
show us to go and talk to your parent
you know it's cooler to go talk to your
friend or even just go and experience it
yourself right so even in that context
or gulia
yeah bad idea a helpful resource for
parents the book by a man named Andy
Crouch it's called the tech wise family
we'll see if we can put that link to
Amazon below it's a good read that will
help you see some principles on how to
guide your children through this whole
technology situation from that same
report we just mentioned previously 37%
of these kids have received a link to
sexually explicit content 15 to 24 year
old's account for nearly half of all STD
diagnosis each year wow that's that's a
pretty you know young young demographic
especially when you're dying too those
15 16 17
once you hit 18 obviously you are
considered to be legally adult or to
make your own decisions
so you also think about the experience
like at that young age you have to
expose yourself in a lot of situations
to develop an STD or you don't have to
but and it's just showing like kids are
really sexually active at that age and
probably don't happened the first time
to be sexually active at that age
prior to being that age you know they're
being primed with information right
they're being fed information to make
them curious to the point where they get
like yeah I'm gonna do this the biggest
online users of pornography are 12 to 17
year old boys that one was kind of a bit
of a surprise to me to think that it was
that young of an age group and you know
what scares me about that is the warped
picture that a young boy is growing up
and having of a woman you know if his
wife doesn't do that or you know his his
mate doesn't perform in this certain way
I mean he's sealing into his mind what
excites him our brains take pictures
especially the male mind takes pictures
in the brain and then tries to recreate
those those activities and so those
young kids that are being exposed to
this are trying to recreate that and
that's not realistic mm-hmm most women
are not gonna do the things that those
win
are doing in those videos and and it's
literally warping their mind to no end
and you can see why now all of a sudden
it's like their idea of a woman is just
what pleasure can she give me which is a
very selfish lustful view of women and
rather than him going what can I do for
my wife that would be a proper context
but and how easily accessible through
these things have to be for a
twelve-year-old to get their hands on it
twelve girls don't have credit cards or
if they take their parents I'm hoping
that the parent should see the bill on
it but you know it's it's easy to just
get access there's so much that way
there's so much free pornography on the
internet there literally does not need
to be any sort of financial exchange
these kids are being exposed to an
incredible amount of terrible things and
this is a warning call to parents you
got to know what your kids are doing you
know know what those devices are put the
safeguards in there because this is the
this is the statistics in the world that
is telling us what the majority of
people are struggling with right here
these creators are like drug dealers you
know they're they're able to put things
out that's like this is your first hit
you know the first hits free get you
hooked and then once they have that
exposure then they're gonna be seeking
after it trying to and then they're
willing to pay for it
it's true there's a reason why it's a
billions billion dollar industry right
so how much of the Internet consists of
pornography four percent of websites
thirteen percent of web searches and
twenty percent of mobile searches why do
you think it's so much higher on mobile
more secret person yeah that's right
sure and percentage of the US adults 18
to 35 who watch porn at least weekly
eighty seven percent of men and twenty
eight and a half percent of women I'm
gonna be throwing quite a few statistics
at you guys just kind of rather rapidly
now so feel free to jump in but we're
gonna kind of go through a lot of a
chain of information about this topic
the world's most popular websites so I
mean what does it come to everybody's
mind right Google right everybody knows
Google
and then after that YouTube and
everybody thinks of Facebook but the
thing that's really surprising to me is
right here and that's pornhub porn hub
is higher than Instagram it's higher
than Amazon it's higher than Netflix
this is the number one pornography
website in the world and it's like about
number eight on the list there's more
people watching porn than there are
regular shows on Netflix I mean it's
it's baffling because you think of the
ones that are above it the only one on
the list that's above that that really
concentrates on video is YouTube all the
rest of them are they either it's a
search engine or it's just kind of
social media which is a variety of
content but most of those are
informational 60% of porn websites are
hosted in the US these are the top ten
countries for websites hosting
pornography and we are number one
yeah it's actually kind of surprising
because there's other countries where
porn or prostitution is legal but that's
one ironic thing you know prostitution
as far as I know is only legal in Vegas
and the United States so it's illegal to
pay a woman for sex but if she's on
camera making a video getting paid
perfectly legal or just ironic I don't
don't get the idea there so this comes
from psychology today what does porn do
to intimacy
they said that number one point free
relationships are stronger with a lower
rate of infidelity I mean that makes
sense right just seems like all you see
exactly number two watching porn
diminishes relationship commitment kinda
goes along with point number one right
number three the fantasy alternative
leads to real-world cheating I love it
that this is Psychology Today this is
not Bible dot bible-thumper car yeah I
mean like this nothing to do with the
religion whatsoever this is literally
the psychologists of the world saying
hey look this is what this thing is
doing to your brain and your
relationship exactly
additionally according to the Olmsted
study they indicated that only men think
that watching pornography has only
positive consequences what man of that
flat phone dare I ask what those
positive consequences are it's been you
know this is often attributed to a male
problem but I believe that they are
starting to find statistics that say
that this is just as much as a female
problem in today's world as it is a male
problem so we'll go back to this quote
these shifts in themes found in popular
music may both influence cultural norms
and choose I think as we look at the
influence of music we look at the
influence of media we've looked at all
these things we can see how it's
changing society you know in very real
ways job said this and 31 verse one he
says I have made a covenant with my eyes
why then should I look upon a young
women if you are sold out to God and you
say God I am yours you have recreated me
you've changed me there's no reason for
me to look on another there's no reason
for me to lust after another woman I
have my spouse I have you it's enough
you know there's a great enough gift and
that to be realized without going
outside of that and according to
psychology today you know you're gonna
reduce your commitment your
you're gonna see downsides that cascade
this makes perfect sense because if you
make a commitment to God loving God it
goes hand in hand with respect when you
look up to God and he transforms you the
next step would be looking towards your
fellow men and how you interact with
your fellow men so what job is saying
makes a lot of sense it's like a natural
reaction or a natural next step to just
loving God that's to respect your fellow
man this is both for men and women and
we're not to be clear we're not talking
about you noticed a girl as guys you
notice women all the time
you might see some girls oh she's
attractive we're talking about when you
are dwelling on that right in a way that
you are entertaining thoughts that you
should not that would be detrimental to
your marriage and your relationship with
God all right so get back to some more
of these statistics just to go back to
this quote that we found from that music
article you know how is society changing
what what are these shifts what is
happening and when we look at statistics
I think what we can find is really
fascinating and this one it asks the
question do you consider gambling
morally acceptable or morally wrong 69
percent of people said morally
acceptable and twenty-eight percent of
people said morally wrong one percent
said depends and 2 percent had no
opinion gambling so according to people
pretty much okay what about do you think
married men and women having an affair
is morally acceptable or morally wrong
10 percent said morally acceptable
88 percent said morally wrong I actually
expected this to be lower given some of
the other things that we've seen but
it's interesting to me people's answers
versus people's behaviors versus what 2
portrayed so we may have a mental assent
what are we acting out on so we're still
doing things that we know or it could be
do you think that pornography is morally
acceptable or morally wrong 43% said
morally acceptable that's a lot and
we're talking about 18 years and older
and this statistic is as late as
team in May this is not as morally
acceptable as gambling for example but
still a good chunk of people out there
like yeah no problem this shopping yeah
my mother and sister are porn stars
that's no less acceptable cheating on
your spouse very wrong
pornography not such a big deal we go
back to the words of Jesus lusting after
a woman you've committed adultery
already with her in your heart so we
need to really need to reevaluate our
morality perhaps here what about this do
you think having a baby outside of
marriage is morally acceptable or
morally wrong 65% of people said it was
morally acceptable 32% said normally
wrong you know I think this is actually
morally wrong because it takes two to
raise a child going back to our
beginning conversation the child needs
to see a picture of a male and a female
together to understand the context and
often when you have a child outside of
wedlock they're bounced around the the
stepdad situation or the stepmom
situation is never the same and often
times and I've heard often times
especially with young girls I mean it's
the stepdad that was raping them you
know and it's like you know a terrible
terrible situation so I wish society saw
this as differently and saying listen
you know a child would be best to have
it a marriage context no not outside the
fact that the majority of people believe
that that is okay is a little alarming
are people born gay or lesbian or does
this develop due to upbringing and
environmental factors this question was
asked in the US and you can see how
people's attitudes have shifted over
time once upon a time you know back in
the 70s people would have said it has to
do with upbringing an environment but
over time we can see how that has
changed but look at the music I was born
this way look at the influence of the
culture exact born in this you know
I think that has an effect it's
interesting to look at these statistics
and look at correlations and things like
music and things like media and see can
we really say it's not affected us but
when we look at how society has changed
over time what are their values what do
they say is morally wrong and right this
is what we've said when we're bold as
Americans our gay or lesbian
relationships morally acceptable you can
see the same kind of trend you know it
goes back to that comment you made and
you know there are TV shows that they'll
just put a character in they don't have
to say anything it's just a nice
neighbor it just shows us how our
attitudes have shifted on what people
consider to be morally acceptable or not
as a society why are you in favor of
same-sex marriage when you look at why
people are in favor of these things it's
interesting what they have to say equal
rights everyone should have the same
rights and freedoms
that's what 32 almost 1/3 of
participants said about the same amount
said personal choice love happiness
matters not sexual orientation and then
they have a host of other reasons
interesting some you know they did
actually bring God into this as an
answer and a five percent of people said
everyone is equal in God's eyes and
that's why they were in favor same-sex
marriage does religion do more harm than
good let's talk about that along with
all these other things people are asked
to what extent do you agree or disagree
with the following statement religion
does more harm in the world than good 49
percent of people would say that
religion does more harm than good and
the pending on where you're at in the
world it's higher like Belgium and
Germany Spain Sweden Great Britain all
higher the United States is on the lower
end you know of this graph 39 percent
Japan being the lowest of the countries
that are listed which I do find that
interesting 39 percent you know when you
really look at the statistics how many
people in America believe in God it's
still more people believe in God then
don't but the media will
have you think o atheist mindset that's
the that's what's normal now and yet
almost foreign ten people say that it
does more harm than good
well that's let's keep in mind we're
talking about religion a Christian who's
not just Christianity there are very
oppressive religions out there so I
understand this statistic yeah why it's
like that let's take a look at the next
one
religions generational decline in the
u.s. this is a percentage of Americans
who say they believe in God pray daily
or attended services once a week so you
have the Silent Generation this is from
1928 to 1945 your baby boomers Gen X
older Millennials and younger
Millennials and if you look what do you
see in every single category pretty much
consistently with the exception of
attending services once a week which is
a pretty close to the same but a slight
rise pretty much a steady decline and
it's interesting how this you know when
we see a steady decline and then we also
see over time our attitudes towards
morals and values and things like that
you know they go ahead and in are you
certain or uncertain about the existence
of a God 54% said absolutely certain
there is a God 16% not sure nine percent
certain there is no God mmm they know
everything and then you got some people
that in the valley of decision know
there's somewhat certain there's a God
somewhat certain there is no God
only about half of teenagers or in this
you know category where they're like
there is it going hmm
I'd like to talk about nine percent see
what their hard proof is for no good we
keep going what do we see about
cohabitation it's a good idea when we
look at cross generations do you look at
Millennials 72 percent think great idea
Gen Xers 69 percent baby boomers
sixty-three percent the elders look at
the huge drop they're 36% you're like no
that's not a good you know but pretty
much after that it's a steady Cline so
is that the class of people that are
like you know having their 50th wedding
anniversaries and stuff right now or is
that baby boomers know the elders there
that's
gonna be the class I like having this 50
year you know anniversaries and you can
see also when people identified as
liberal versus conservative what they
thought was a good idea or not if they
were a liberal that 86% said yeah it's a
great idea that's because they're
probably mostly doing it and only 37
percent said we don't think that's a
good idea
what about when we look at this
cohabitation if it's a good idea
practicing Christian versus people of no
faith 41% of Christians said we think
cohabitation is a good idea you take God
out of the equation and people's
attitudes towards morality changes yeah
so true this is views on trician all
traditional Christian sexual ethics part
to you this is also from Barna Group and
we can look at practicing Christians no
faith and other faith this is the idea
that traditional Christian sexual ethics
teaches that sex should only be within a
marriage between a man and a woman which
of the following words if any best
describes your opinion of those ethics
so 53% of practicing Christians said
that was a moral idea 36% of people with
no faith said it was unrealistic other
faiths 28% of them said a moral idea but
you can look at this and see how
attitudes change depending on what
column you fall in this is the
percentage of high school students in
the u.s. who had smoked cigarettes in
their lifetime in 2015 to 2017 by gender
and sexual orientation okay what do you
see - the more they stray away from
heterosexual more risky maybe they are
the next one is these are the same group
of people who had drunk alcohol and by
gender and sexual orientation
what do you see same thing
yeah more leveled out but basically it's
it's still higher yeah you can still
deduct that a heterosexual group
actually has a little bit probably less
of a risk take you know and then you
look at the next one and this is cocaine
use same in the same group and now what
do you see they mail something less
stressed you know you know I was I was
looking over the statistics I'm
wondering like wow you know it's like
yeah cigarettes alcohol cocaine it's
pretty much all basically the same kind
of trend you know what is going on here
and I've often wondered you know these
other groups are they depressed are they
you know feeling some kind of societal
pressure that brings on a depression
what's going on that you would have more
high incidence of those abuses versus
heterosexual this was in 2006 and these
are going to talk about a group of
people called Buster's Buster's are
people who are born between 1965 and
1983 okay so if you fall into that
category here at Buster but many
Buster's also defy sexual and convention
in their attitudes for instance more
than two-thirds of the generations set
that cohabitation and sexual fantasies
are morally acceptable behaviors
compared with half of older adults most
young adults contended that engaging in
sex outside of marriage and viewing
pornography are not morally problematic
while only one-third of pre Buster's
agreed
almost half of Buster's believed that
sexual relationships between people of
the same sex are acceptable compared
with one-quarter of older adults
people's attitudes are changing over
time was there a stat on each groups
like happiness and mental states and
things like that no I didn't have that
in the article okay
they also said teens and young adults
said not recycling is more immoral than
viewing pornographic
yes whoa I was just like wow I mean I'm
totally against the littering so this is
recycling every cycling like like that
yeah that's like you better be driving
an electric car and you know recycling
your plastic you don't know put that
aluminum can all that trash can but hey
you want to watch this porn with me yeah
really puts into perspective like the
worth of human life as opposed to other
things mm-hmm I mean if you if you
actually just analyze the people that go
through the sex industry their lives are
rooms they actually even have a a you
know how you get a motorcycle and I tell
you you've got seven years to live when
you get this motorcycle license that
same thing applies in the porn industry
they'll actually tell the women they
have a shelf life and that shelf life is
really short and fast that's right when
they're in 18 by the time they're 25 a
lot of them are just messed up I don't
know what the actual statistic is but I
find that interesting that we care less
about their lives than we do some
plastic same report no I'm sorry
different report but also from the Barna
Group some of these differences show up
in sexual activities engaged and during
the past month but Buster's were twice
as likely to have viewed sexually
sexually explicit movies or videos two
and a half times more likely to report
having a sexual encounter outside of
marriage and three times more likely to
a viewed sexually graphic content online
if anyone what generation here and you
are
I guess bending the rules of sexuality
bending morality to you know your own
generational viewpoints you know people
are changing over time go back to your
statisti how would you rate the state of
moral values in the United States today
excellent good only fair or poor look
how many people said poor given all that
the information that we've covered at
this point in time we have almost 50
percent of people would say our
moralities are poor it
the truth they are they're being honest
with themselves and they're insensitive
to the reality of it and sensitive to
the reality but you know it's
interesting to me that we have a lot of
similarities with Rome like and and just
before Rome fell there was a direct link
with the sexual twisted nough sin that
Society and it's like now all of a
sudden we are cruising down that same
pathway we have a lot of twisted sexual
understandings and and and things that
are in our world and where we're headed
down the same path they fell from Pew
Research Center this one shows us that
attitude towards the change in moral
values over the past 50 years in the
u.s. by generation changing for the
better
guess who was the highest group that
said we're changing for the better it
was the Millennials and it just goes
down from there and course conversely
changing for the worse
you know the Silent Generation that
older generation baby boomers right
behind him beliefs about morality by
generation again from the Barna Group
what is morally right and wrong changes
over time based on society those no set
moral yeah I mean you just yeah it's
it's in flux it just changes with
society yeah it's it's fluid ethically
fluid that's scary it is because you
know what's what's right yesterday may
not be right tomorrow so bring it Rome
you know throw them in the Coliseum
let's watch I still have a party and you
have celebrate Brandon's circus sex and
violence that's a Roman struggle to
Islam this one was really staggering to
me really staggering
Barney group reported this an article
that said Christians say they do best at
relationships worst in Bible knowledge
really sad and and here's my question is
how can you confidently say that you do
best in relationships if you're least in
Bible knowledge because the entire Bible
is about relationships
and the entire ten commandments is your
relationships it's a relationship with
God your relationship with man so if you
don't know what the Bible teaches about
relationships you can say I'm great at
relationships because you're not
comparing with the Bible and the Bible
is a book full of people's examples of
what happened in their relationship and
they're not always positive stories but
what we can do is we can look at those
stories and because hey look look look
how that turned out
maybe should stay away from the way that
that guy dealt with it you know if you
have 700 wives might liji illumines
stray you know the if I can boil a lot
of this down into more or less more you
know it's a synced thought or one
thought relationships anymore
earth becoming less and less about
loving and they're becoming more about
loving yourself or making sure that
number one is taken care of we get this
idea that love is selfish love is about
me it's about what I want right it's
about personal satisfaction and that has
become the highest priority the Bible
says in Psalm 101 3 and 4 says I will
set nothing wicked before my eyes
I hate the work of those who follow 8 it
shall not cling to me a perverse heart
shall depart from me I will not know
wickedness if we don't know what the
Bible says about relationships how could
we ever expect to be good how could we
ever expect to know what we would put in
front of our eyes or not we'd have
nothing to measure it by and if you have
nothing to measure it by your back to
ethically fluid no it just goes without
saying what's what's right yesterday may
not be right tomorrow because you have
no ruler no guy hmm Bible also says turn
away my eyes from looking at worthless
things and revive me in your way this is
a prayer that all of us should have
because it's so easy to fall into that
trap of looking at things that are
worthless looking at things that can
waste your time looking at things that
will drag you down and if you're a
parent you know some of the best I've
advice I've heard you need to teach your
kids that if they stumble onto something
the
it becomes apparent they should not be
looking at do not freak out on your kid
just make it clear to them like hey if
you ever see something that you come
across you shouldn't look at you know
you have little brothers and sisters
make sure you take them out of the room
come get me and I'll take care of it
that's what we need to be doing with our
kids there are all kinds of tools the
people can use to help guard their eyes
I'll mention one of them one of them is
called covenant eyes have you heard of
covenant ice covenant eyes is a computer
programming it's installed and it can be
put I think now on smartphone devices as
well and it will send a log of
everything that you look at to somebody
of your choice and account a bit with
water if you are tempted to look at
something that you shouldn't and you go
down that road somebody is looking right
besides just God Almighty because is
always looking and probably also in the
back of your head is if you know
somebody can rat you out
you're probably gonna think twice about
whether you do that and you might be
doing the right thing for not entirely
the right reason but it's a good
deterrent but sometimes we need that
kind of strong measure to be able to get
rid of something like this I mean God
created sexuality to be a bonding glue
to us and he created it is a very strong
substance and so when we miss glue that
to something it takes drastic measures
like that sometimes to get out of that
and of course using the tool of
embarrassment it's probably a pretty
good one yeah some more Bible advice 2nd
Timothy 2:22 it says flee also youthful
us but pursue righteousness faith love
peace with those who call on the Lord
out of a pure heart I love that
instruction because the Bible isn't just
saying don't do this don't do that
but when you when you were limb push
these things fill it with this you know
fill that hole maybe you find yourself
in that situation where it's like you
know what I know my heart isn't right
you know I know I've done things that I
shouldn't know I am struggling right
this is a very good prayer that you can
pray I think it's from Psalm 139 23 and
24 says search me O God and know my
heart try me and know my anxieties and
see if there is any wicked way in me and
lead me in the way everlasting you give
God that permission to come in and clean
house
he doesn't care how dirty it is because
he's seen it all you know I don't care
how bad you think your life is God has
seen worse the Bible says we're in D and
self-seeking exist confusion and every
evil thing are there there's a lot of
confusion in our world these days and
just to tie that in sexually you know
envy and self seeking you know if which
is the very definition of lust
you know then every evil thing can
happen so the devil knows listen our
sexuality is intertwined with our
spirituality if if the devil can mess up
your sexuality he can mess up your
spirituality you know and so this is a
telltale verse right here that really
lets us know you know guard well those
avenues to the soul and because this is
one of the avenues that the devil is is
certainly using to get at us all right
well that is all we have today for love
is what you know being the question fo
as I went through all this information I
was like wow what has love become you
know love is my life you know maybe
there's a follow-up presentation we'll
do some time I have a second part to
this that focuses more on the spiritual
aspect called what is love but for now
it's love as what this has been an LED
live episode talking about sexuality and
all the things going on in our world and
where morality is going to where society
is going how people's attitudes are
shifting and why you should be careful
as a parent you guys have any final
thoughts that you want to share with our
viewers I just like how you showed clear
evidence that media does affect society
we can see it warping and shifting and
being molded by media at large and it's
one more thing I want to add for parents
I had really encourage you to not lose
hope don't lose heart because with all
these influences of the devil that are
surrounding us and children God isn't in
charge he's in control
that's her so I encourage you to do your
best and just remember that God was with
the rest and with much prayer comes much
power is any part good point men no
raise up a child in the way she should
go when he's older he will not depart
from it I'm just thinking that I want to
really encourage the viewers out here
you know you guys have just seen one
presentation we did some research for
this Keith did a wonderful job looking
at all these statistics making sense of
this you guys if you have small children
you guys have relationships look this
subject up if you're looking for a way
to approach your own children do some
research yourself trust me this is one
of the greatest gifts that God gave us
to have this beautiful thing in our
relationships that we share together and
and the devil is just wreaking havoc on
these things and he's literally kicking
people out of churches because of this
this topic so if you guys want to look
more into this we want to encourage you
guys do some research subscribe to our
Channel and we got lots of topics on
this kind of thing if you want to see
what the media does and how it affects
you look at some of our other LEDs in
our Channel and we thank you for
watching and we'll see you later
god bless figure